And this is a tricky one, but the keywords are used when describing
the moon's Jupiter where predictable and regular.
Predictable means Galileo could make a chart or some catalogue of the times
when each of these moons were supposed to let's say go behind the planet Jupiter.
If we're looking at the zoomed in version of Jupiter, we could tell when this transit occurred
because the moon will go from being visible to no longer visible when it passed behind the planet,
and it didn't matter if you're observing over here in Italy or may be over here
somewhere in Africa let's say--this would happen at the exact same time.
It doesn't matter if you're Galileo here in Italy or some sailor out in the ocean.
You would've observed this transit to occur at the exact same time.
So if you knew for instance that this occurred at 8 o'clock in Italian time, this sailor could immediately
get a reference for what time it was back at home.
By comparing that with their own clock, they could determine their longitude.
Seems pretty brainy right?